let me fight in my whole life it's not a
choice for me every punch ever thrown
has been a mall you might show me how to
do this I mean she was well and so I
loved the film and did you feel any
pressure taking on the rocky story no
not on this one only because I know
working with you know Ryan Coogler again
and sly and slide the woman that you
know I did give me such a favor by
taking the pressure off my shoulders he
told me before way before we even
started like this is an Iraqi 7 this is
Crete 1 this is your film and I'm here
to support you so don't try to you know
doing imitate me or you know or try to
live up to anything that you know the I
did 40 years ago just do your do your
own thing so for me stepping up you know
the said everyday I just didn't have I
didn't feel that pressure good and then
obviously getting through a crystal
versus that iron is pretty amazing in
itself and was that one sneak off the
book at this say uh-oh
the bucket list yeah
working with sly it wasn't on the bucket
list because I didn't even think that
was an option
yeah you know and so it was kind of nice
little like gift that kind of came you
know so okay so for me to be able to
work with something that I never saw
coming and it was I'm just so happy that
I did alright and then you've worked
with some incredible actors is there
anyone male or female that you'd love to
work with Jennifer Lawrence yeah sure I
definitely won't work with her she's an
incredible actress and and I would love
to kind of do something where for sure
this time this lat it's a lot but
definitely for sure Jennifer okay great
and now that your mega buff and I have
to say you have the best arms ever by
the way
and if Channing Tatum was looking for a
please and the magic might move a the
next one would you be up for it yeah for
sure I'll be fine you got nice memes
yeah I mean we can find him fine it'll
finally move somewhere but not like
Channing is a great guy we're actually
hanging out at the globe yesterday which
is pretty cool yeah I would definitely
do that way home okay I want that to
happen so there's Oscars buzz around
crease so fingers crossed and are you
excited about the Oscars and I follow
you on Instagram I know you're like a
celebrity selfie he would be on your hit
list that night
hey but you always have pieces with
celebs on your of em no afraid to rot
through a pic no I mean they're usually
my friends yeah I'm not I'm not at all
so would I have anybody on my oh my
headless for so take yourself you with
um something with Ellen I think she
brushed you broke been in there yeah a
couple years ago I invite more people in
but yeah and so I'm a huge Friday Night
Lights fan and still missed a show those
softly I was very excited about meeting
me today and please tell me you still
hang out with some of the cast members
over Pfizer not nice I haven't in a
while but we're all really close but I
just saw Matt Lauria got the Globes as
well
Darren Phillips who played Billy coach
Taylor you know saying Kyle Chandler we
we text every so often we all stay in
touch like that show was so such a
tight-knit group we're like one big
family so everybody kind of goes off and
does their thing and you know and we
wish them well and you know we
definitely you know whenever we see each
other it's like a family reunion Bob
okay lovely to meet you
no problem has to meet you too
a great fighter once said it ain't about
how hard you can hit
it's about how hard you can get
and keep moving forward just got here
that's the toughest opponent you're ever
gonna have to face I believe that's true
in the ring and I think that's true life
there show me something